Cancer, the most beautiful of the four seasons of Mt. Hallasan It's
winter now and the
rice paddy fields fall and snow falls like this on every tree, then it's really beautiful
Oh oh
, my mother, Mt. Halla of Jeju Island
, stopped all activities at
around the 5,000 won temple, but it is a thankful mountain that has supported the vast nature and ecosystems around me until now.
Hallasan, etc.
According to many legends passed down,
Hallasan has been at its peak from humans and gods for a long time because of its power snake
.
1 This is what it looks like from below.
When you go into that mountain, it's really cold and windy and snowy that you can't even imagine.
Nature such as plants and animals
Owen suicide of Mt. Halla, and it is impossible without respect for those who come down to the ground and stay for a while fascinated by the magnificence of the mountain
.
A huge
mountain comes out when Seolmun-jaalman makes Jeju Island t Mapo In addition, it is left in the soil and piled up, and a large mountain comes out of it, and the mountain is sold right away
.
According to legend, there is a Bayer Opera in honor of his mother, who died as he died.
Hallasan is my own highest mountain and the most sacred mountain.
It's high enough to pull
[Music]
Jeju Island Hae-in deer is
a symbol of luck When the clouds stay and the wind blows, Dam
is a sacred place where spirits come down and play on the backs of white deer
Standing on the top of Palatal on a dark night
now
Calling the twinkling stars in the sky with gratitude for the long journey to . The act of travelling is also said to bring
luck to the place.
Respect the freedom. Then I met the better 4r Hallasan Mountain. I think there will be
[Music]